في الوقت الذي سار فيه الوقت إلى الأمام ، بقيت العديد من
العناصر التي تركت وراءها في 11 سبتمبر
2001 كما كانت في يوم الثلاثاء الآن
خلف الزجاج الذي يلعب دوره في
وعد يبلغ الآن من العمر 20 عامًا ألا ينسى أبدًا أن
حقيبة الصالة الرياضية تخص أصغر
راكب على متن الرحلة 93.
في الواقع ، في طريق عودتها إلى
الكلية في ذلك اليوم ، تم عرض
القطع الأثرية في اليوم الذي
توفي فيه 2977 شخصًا على نطاق واسع
في المتاحف في جميع أنحاء البلاد
لجعل الماضي أكثر واقعية في
العناصر الأيقونية الأخرى من السنوات
العشرين الماضية التي يكون جمهورها أصغر ومحدّدًا.
الغرض من
استخدام القطع الأثرية هنا في متحف وكالة المخابرات المركزية ،
يمكننا أن نحكي قصة إنجازاتنا
ما فعلناه مع تاريخنا
ونبين لهم المهام المختلفة التي
حدثت ومساعدتهم على فهم
ما يمكنهم القيام به في المستقبل
متحف وكالة المخابرات المركزية هو نادر
متحف غير مفتوح للجمهور ، عالق في
عمق مقر الوكالة في لانجلي
فيرجينيا أسفل الممرات الشهيرة التي
يراها معظم الأمريكيين فقط في الأفلام ما لم
يعجبهم المتحف  مدير روبرت باير ، أنت
تعمل هنا ، هذا ليس مجرد تاريخ من
أجل التاريخ ، فنحن نريد من ضباطنا أن
ينظروا إلى هذه القطع الأثرية ، ثم ربما
يأتون بفكرة جديدة
لمهمة تحدث
اليوم ، تعود المجموعة إلى عالم ما قبل وكالة المخابرات المركزية
كان مكتب الخدمات الإستراتيجية ، وهو سلف استخباراتي للحرب الثانية ،
هو التاريخ الأكثر وضوحًا بعد أسبوعين فقط من أحداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر 2001 ، حيث أرسلت وكالة المخابرات المركزية
فريقها الأول إلى أفغانستان
للبحث عن أسامة بن لادن بحلول أواخر عام 2010 ،
وكانوا قد ركزوا على مجمع في
باد أباد  في شمال باكستان ، قامت
وكالة الاستخبارات الجغرافية المكانية الوطنية
ببناء نماذج مصغرة مثل هذا النموذج
لإحاطة الأختام البحرية التي تستعد
لتنفيذ الغارة وكان الرئيس أوباما لديه
إرهابي ، ولكن كان لديه أيضًا جدار بطول ستة أقدام
حتى لا يتمكن أحد من
رؤية هذا عن قرب
يساعدهم الرئيس على فهم
شيء أكثر من مجرد صورة فوتوغرافية
هنا أيضًا واحدة من 13 قطعة من الطوب تم جمعها
من المجمع والبندقية التي تم العثور عليها
بجوار بن لادن عندما قُتل
في 2 مايو.  2011. وجود هذه القطعة الأثرية هنا في
المقر يسلط الضوء حقًا على أن عملية البحث
عن أسامة بن لادن والعثور
عليه أخيرًا وتقديمه إلى العدالة ليست
كل الآلاف من العناصر الموجودة في
مجموعة المتحف ملحوظة مثل
بندقية بن لادن أو هذه المروحية
التي حلقت أولًا  أرسل فريق 911 CIA
إلى أفغانستان والذي يجلس أيضًا في
الحرم الجامعي ولكنهم معروضون جميعًا هنا حت
يتذكر الضباط ما سيحدث أم
مهم وكيف يمكنهم تشكيل ما
و التالي في لانجلي فيرجينيا أنا كا
ين كيفا